[Music]
and the Fantastic Marin Morris welcome
to my church can I get a hallelujah
hallelujah
yeah that's the incredible maren Morris
on the latest episode of RuPaul's Drag
Race season 15. Marin was a special
guest judge and went backstage during
untucked where she apologized for
country music's treatment of the lgbtq
plus Community coming from country music
and its relationship with like lgbtq
Plus members I just want to say I'm
sorry and I love you guys for making me
feel like a brave voice in country music
while backstage the season 15 drag
artists also thanked Marin for using her
voice just you being here shows your
ally yeah thank you
I love hearing Marin share her story
because a lot of times we're country
artists they can't really Express their
more Progressive ideals just her being
her shows she's down and convolved with
the LGBT now Marin has been very vocal
over the years of her support for the
lgbtq plus Community last year she
called out Jason Aldean's wife Brittany
Aldean after Britney shared transphobic
remarks Marin called her Insurrection
Barbie and a scumbag human on Twitter
put that tweet in the Country Music Hall
of Fame thank you Marin for using your
voice and continuing to be one of the
few country artists to be an outspoken
Ally